you pick up the phone, you can guess
or predict what this phone call is about.
It's because of an injection of intelligence into a process
which was considered dead for a long time in the West.
And the last kind of innovation, invisible innovation
coming out of India is what we call management innovation.
It's not a new product or a new process
but a new way to organize work,
and the most significant management innovation to come
out of India, invented by the Indian offshoring industry
is what we call the global delivery model.
What the global delivery model allows is, it allows you
to take previously geographically core-located tasks,
break them up into parts, send them around the world
where the expertise and the cost structure exists,
and then specify the means for reintegrating them.
Without that, you could not have any of the other
invisible innovations today.
So, what I'm trying to say is, what we are finding
in our research is, that if products for end users
is the visible tip of the innovation iceberg,
India is well represented in the invisible, large,
submerged portion of the innovation iceberg.
Now, this has, of course, some implications,
and so we developed three implications of this research.
The first is what we called sinking skill ladder,
and now I'm going to go back to where I started my
conversation with you, which was about the flight of jobs.
Now, of course, when we first, as a multinational company,
decide to outsource jobs to India in the R&D,
what we are going to do is we are going to outsource the
bottom rung of the ladder to India, the least sophisticated jobs,
just like Tom Friedman would predict.
Now, what happens is, when you outsource the bottom rung
of the ladder to India for innovation and for R&D work,
at some stage in the very near future you are going to have
to confront a problem,
which is where does the next step
of the ladder people come from within your company?
So you have two choices then:
Either you bring the people from India into
the developed world to take positions in the next step
of the ladder — immigration —
or you say, there's so many people in the bottom step
of the ladder waiting to take the next position in India,
why don't we move the next step to India?
What we are trying to say is
that once you outsource the bottom end of the ladder, you --
it's a self-perpetuating act, because of the sinking skill ladder,
and the sinking skill ladder is simply the point that
you can't be an investment banker
without having been an analyst once.
You can't be a professor without having been a student.
You can't be a consultant without having been a research associate.
So, if you outsource the least sophisticated jobs,
at some stage, the next step of the ladder has to follow.
The second thing we bring up is what we call
the browning of the TMT, the top management teams.
If the R&D talent is going to be based out of India
and China, and the largest growth markets
are going to be based out of India and China,
you have to confront the problem that
your top management of the future
is going to have to come out of India and China,
because that's where the product leadership is,
that's where the important market leadership is.
Right? And the last thing we point out in this slide,
which is, you know, that to this story, there's one caveat.
India has the youngest growing population in the world.
This demographic dividend is incredible, but paradoxically,
there's also the mirage of mighty labor pools.
Indian institutes and educational system,
with a few exceptions, are incapable of producing students
in the quantity and quality needed
to keep this innovation engine going,
so companies are finding innovative ways to overcome this,
but in the end it does not absolve the government
of the responsibility for creating this educational structure.
So finally, I want to conclude
by showing you the profile of one company, IBM.
As many of you know, IBM has always been considered
for the last hundred years to be one of the most
innovative companies.
In fact, if you look at the number of patents filed over history,
I think they are in the top or the top two or three companies
in the world of all patents filed in the USA as a private company.
Here is the profile of employees of
IBM over the last decade.
In 2003, they had 300,000 employees,
or 330,000 employees, out of which, 135,000
were in America, 9,000 were in India.
In 2009, they had 400,000 employees, by which time
the U.S. employees had moved to 105,000,
whereas the Indian employees had gone to 100,000.
Well, in 2010, they decided they're not going to reveal
this data anymore, so I had to make some estimates
based on various sources.
Here are my best guesses. Okay? I'm not saying
this is the exact number, it's my best guess.
It gives you a sense of the trend.
There are 433,000 people now at IBM, out of which
98,000 are remaining in the U.S.,
and 150,000 are in India.
So you tell me, is IBM an American company,
or an Indian company? (Laughter)
Ladies and gentlemen, thank you very much. (Applause)